next category next category [ __ ] i
don't want to see this [ __ ] anymore
all right let's get the next category
out i can't believe it best out of
context clip
oh i i i oh this this should be an
interesting so many good ones
yeah you mean you mean 50 of the
subreddit is this well i think
what we should do we should just we
should just let play all the clips not
say anything yeah
yeah yeah as you would experience yeah
it's out of context so these are the top
four nominations of best out of context
clip
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang
[Music]
that was from because i remember i
remember doing this actually and i'm
just like wait [ __ ]
i probably shouldn't have done that it's
a gift it's immortalized
yeah yeah i knew i knew it was going to
be taken out of context
episode right yeah from the entire
episode all right second one
no no it's the opposite oh i'd rather
something out my ass than down my throat
there is no way you stand by that i
stand by it oh god
what i love about this clip is that the
way you say with such conviction yeah
it's like him out of nowhere
i stand by this yeah and this one is
actually from one of the trash taste
streams which if you're not following
our third channel then you would have
probably
subscribed to this one when i worked at
[ __ ] mcdonald's like that wasn't
challenging
and i'd go home and i'd be like right
now i want to be like [ __ ] mentally
challenged
yeah that sounds awful
it was a very poor choice of words yeah
very very important i was just like
phrasing the clip
that was terrible
and then this one oh this might be my
favorite this one this i think to this
day is still the highest rating what
why is this the top rated clip
but that one that just sticks out to you
it's just like you meet somebody or i
should i guess specify
that one convention story where somebody
was the biggest [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah because
get someone who looks at you the way god
looks at the corona
do you remember why you could not
remember this what were you thinking
about
i have no [ __ ] clue because the thing
is like this
this is like a clip where you know it's
you know you know when you just
do things when someone else is talking
and you forget that you're on camera
i have no idea what the [ __ ] i was doing
just kind of hope that when you do
something weird that it's on someone
else
like i do not remember what i was
thinking i was thinking you know sydney
was probably
probably talking no one's like
concentrating on me um
and if if it wasn't for trash taste then
this would have never been filmed
and it's now like the highest rated post
on reddit why
i don't know why this is so funny
there's so many other good [ __ ] clips
and fan art and everything
and this this is the top clip of all
time
what it's because the mind boggles right
it's like what was he thinking there
like what was going on in his hand like
what made him laugh at that moment it's
like the inside out meme where they go
like i wonder what he's thinking about
which one do you want to win boys
because i personally i want the bang
bang bang i really want the bang bang
bang i really love that one
it's just it's such a it literally
encapsulates out of context
perfectly i think i i i want the i'd
rather something up my ass and down my
that is a good one
just just because just because it was
like such it came out [ __ ] nowhere
and that line hit like a truck i'm just
like what the [ __ ]
that ass i don't even remember saying
that all right she found out who won
gentlemen
all right let's find out best out of
context
[Music]
out of context clip goes to
gone realizes he's drinking corona yes
thank you subreddit thank you we did a
subreddit and that's right this is from
episode 20.
your uploads were not put in vain get
this off the top rated get it off
stop uploading this get this off i
wanted there how much did it win by a
landslide was it
was it was it not even 36 36 percent
that's pretty good what was the second
place one without contact
like this i've never had to deal with
this with my in my life before right
because i've never had it
i'm never on camera because i had never
had the camera pointed them to me so i
didn't know i was doing this [ __ ] and
now i'm just like
man i do a lot of weird [ __ ] when i'm
not thinking
you know what the day that this that
something tops this for like the top
rated post of all time i'm actually
going to open a bottle of champagne
yeah i'm excited i wonder what could top
this what could possibly top the
wholesomeness of garten just
laughing at a corrupted there's a part
of me that just forever wants this to be
the top you know
for as long as you do trash tapes